Speaker 1: We previously discussed the
11 year old girl involved in Texas who
testified to Congress about her experiences
watching her friend and her teacher get killed.
And one of the things that I, I think
when I watch something like that is
surely everyone's overcome with emotion and thinks
we have to act, we have to implement at least
some common sense gun reform. We can talk also
about mental health and all those things. But.
Step one common sense gun reform, universal
background checks, red flag laws, waiting periods,
raising the age for when you can get guns.
Right. Well, as you'll know, that's not the
way that everyone responds to these tragedies.
Unfortunately. Fortunately, a lot of people,
Republican politicians specifically see their
whole job when a tragedy like this happens as
standing in the way of anything from being done.
At least on the issue of guns, nothing can happen
in regard to gun control after these tragedies,
and that's what they see their job as. And
they kind of offer up vague solutions,
as I kind of alluded to early. Oh,
it's mental health always. It's school security,
but they don't propose specific solutions. And
then their primary focus is distracting from the
big blinking red LED sign, which is gun control.
And Louie Gohmert did this exactly on the
House floor recently saying that guy's
saying that the reason maybe the reason
the mass shootings have gone up is
because kids don't pray in school anymore.
Speaker 6: We were told in debate last week,
don't want to hear anymore about social
media, violent video games, Hollywood
mental illness. And they sure don't want to hear
any more about prayers. They're disgusted, hearing
about prayers. They don't want to hear anymore
about fatherlessness, drug use. Look, maybe
if we heard more prayers from leaders of this
country, instead of taking God's name in vain,
we wouldn't had the mass killings like we didn't
have before. Prayer was eliminated from school.
Speaker 1: What do you say to that? I
know this is such a cliche thing, but
Louis, how do you sleep with yourself? Honestly,
I know that someone like Louie Gohmert is
completely aware that implementing common
sense gun reform that would not be infringing
on anyone's Second Amendment right. Would
save lives. It would save countless lives.
But for some reason, whether it's
appealing to a radical part of its base,
keeping those MNRE funds flowing, I don't
know what his reason is, but for some reason
he would rather stand in the way of doing any
of that, and he would rather say, Oh, maybe
it's because kids don't pray in school. Really?
Imagine staring in the face of all of the evidence
that shows the reason why America stands so much
apart or set so much apart from all these other
countries. And the level of gun violence we have
is because we don't have. Common sense gun laws.
Imagine looking at all that evidence and going,
I don't care. I would rather. Not just ignore the
evidence, but actively work against anyone from
acting in a logical manner based on that evidence
to prevent tragedies from happening in
this country. Honestly, that clip looks
like someone doing a parody of a anti-gun reform
Republican politician. Like that's not even real.
Oh, no, it's not a gun. It's not the
lack of gun reform or the lack of
common sense gun laws. It's kids not
doing their morning prayer in class.
You don't believe that? No way. Anyone will
believe that. And I'm so down again, like I'll
says a thousand times whenever these conversations
come up, let's invest in mental health. Let's try
to promote happy, healthy, supporting families,
less secure our schools. But then let's also
implement common sense gun reform. It's just not
that hard. But he makes it hard. People like him
make it hard and they try to distract.
And even as ludicrous as ways as saying,
oh, it's morning prayers that have gone away
that cause these mass shootings at schools.